Russian President
Vladimir Putin is speaking.
Let's listen in.
And attempts to thwart mutiny
are going to have no results.
There have been
consolidation of the society.
The strong
position in and support
was taken by
religious confessions, political
In fact, the whole Russian socie
everyone was united
by the main think responsibility
for the fate of our motherland.
From the very beginning.
All the necessary actions on
neutralization of
the threat have been taken.
The armed mutiny would have been
and destroyed.
In any case, the organizers,
despite the loss of
mind,
should have realized this.
Despite
the unprecedented pressure
from outside
when our comrades are dying in t
The organizers of the mutiny
by betraying
their country
with forcing
the enemies of Russia
and the neo-Nazis
and different types of treachero
These soldiers of Russia
regime with the military
service personnel.
So in the final analysis,
Russia would lose,
and our society has broken up
because of this.
They've lost the arms
for their failures
on the front for that counter cr
But we have to count on the fact
that all our military
service personnel, workers
service personnel, all those
security forces
have shown their loyalty, their
the courage
for the heroes, for the pilots o
This this tragedy is due in addi
we know that the overwhelming ma
of the fighters are patriots of
and just with their people,
that people for the state,
they've proven that courage.
Freeing Donbass
and trying to use
against their brothers
who fought together for the coun
Therefore know from the very beg
But
we've undertaken steps to
avoid a big bloodshed,
including giving the possibility
think for those yet to understan
that the actions have decisively
rejected by society.
The destructive consequences
for Russia,
for the state
of such adventurism,
which tragedy could lead to?
I think great thanks to those so
who've taken the only right deci
in their political
To stop the flowing of blood,
the bloodshed
is today
you have the possibility
to have a contract
with the Ministry of Defense
and all of this to come back to
who are their nearest and deares
in this.
This address will be used.
I repeat the choice for each of
I'm convinced it will be a choic
of the military in Russia
who've recognized their mistakes
I'm grateful to the president of
Alexander Lukashenko, for his ef
and his contribution
for this peaceful resolution.
But I repeat that these
this patriotism
of the Russian society
made a decisive step and made it
for us
together to overcome
the most difficult situation.
Thank you.
I thank you
We have been listening
to Russian President Vladimir
Putin talk
about what we saw
unfold this week in Kiev
gaining promotion.
The head of the Wagner mercenary
apparently attempting a coup,
headed toward Moscow,
now denying it,
saying that this was not a coup,
but rather a protest.
Vladimir Putin
responding, saying
that this was a mutiny, saying
that these soldiers betrayed
Russia, describing them
as neo-Nazis, traitors of the ho
who try to break up our society.
He says that
the Kremlin
has taken steps
to try to avoid bloodshed.
Yet he offered these troops
an opportunity
to come back
and sign contracts
with the Ministry of Defense.
Quite a statement from,
in effect, absorb them, right?
That's what these.
That's how promotion perceived
These offers to sign regular con
with the Russian regular
army was
that they would be taken away
as a power center for him.
And listen,
you know, having reported over
these last few days, on this
first the rebellion
and now this this peace deal, as
This is a Russian president
who is not making nice with Prig
I mean, he's
accusing him of betraying his co
No, but he's also trying to make
to be this leader who had no fol
Which is interesting
because we've seen the pictures
and there were people
who were supporting Prigozhin.
Ultimately, did he have enough s
Maybe not. That may be why he bl
But you also saw Vladimir
Putin blinking as well.
And that is certainly to be clea
I want to get now
to CNN's Matthew Chance,
who is in Moscow.
Matthew, what is your takeaway f
Well, actually, we're
a little nonplused by it here be
we thought
the statements
were going to be a lot more dram
There was sort of the Kremlin wa
speaking up
beforehand, saying that this sta
would determine
the fate of the
of the Russian state of Russia.
And it doesn't seem to have done
that, just seems to have,
you know,
reiterated, you know, a lot of t
I think we've already been talki
about quite a lot
since this armed rebellion was p
I think what's most interesting
sitting here in Moscow watching
is that it's
you know, it's been so long
since we've seen
Vladimir Putin in public, hasn't
and actually said anything
since this rebellion was was
what was put down
or whether it was negotiated awa
or whatever happened.
And so,
you know,
finally, we've seen the Russian
president sort of stand up
in front of the nation, condemn
this armed uprising, reiterate t
that had been offered
to the Wagner fighters
who didn't take part, which is t
they'll be offered
contracts are being offered cont
with the Russian military,
Russian military,
and also condemn
the loss of life that did occur.
And, of course, we've not spoken
I don't think about the fact
that several Russian aircraft
were shot out of the sky
by Wagner forces with a number o
being killed.
And Vladimir
Putin referred to that loss of l
and, of course, condemned it.